HBO's hit show Silicon Valley returns
for a third season on Sunday the network
also announced today that Silicon Valley
along with Game of Thrones and veep are
also getting renewed for new seasons in
2017 I sat down with the executive
producers of Silicon Valley
Mike judge and Alec Berg along with
their secret weapon
former Twitter CEO Dick Costolo who
joined the show this season as a
consultant I started by asking about the
fate of Richard Hendricks the show's
main character who was fired from his
company Pied Piper at the end of last
season in an epic cliffhanger when we
started sort of doing the research for
this season we talked to a lot of
different people about well what would
actually happen if a guy like Richard
got fired from a company like that
mm-hmm
and it was really interesting all of the
engineers that we talked to we said
would the company work without Richard
there and they're like no of course not
it's an engineering based company would
never work and then we talked to VCS and
they were like yeah we get rid of
founders all the time what's the problem
so everybody had a very different idea
of what reality would be so Dick Costolo
what was the dose of reality that you
brought to the writers room as I was
saying earlier before we're on there it
would be hard to understate my influence
on anything you're gonna see you know
sitting in the back of the room and
going yeah you can totally do that that
would absolutely happen yeah you can
keep going a lot worse than that
is there anything where you said no
absolutely really very rarely it was
usually yeah you can make it you can
make it more dramatic than that so what
was it like having a real CEO in the
writers room it was it was amazing and
we get stuck a lot because we try and
hew as much as we can to reality and a
lot of times we'll come up with
something we're like all right we better
call some people and ask them whether
this would actually happen or not and
having him in the room was amazing
because as we were thinking in stangs we
could be looking at him going is this
real what this happened and I imagine I
mean you're an improv comedian by
background I imagine this was also
kind of fun yes no 100% you know I think
there was it was about three weeks
before I deign to suggest you know I
thought I would have things I think this
you know this was I have an idea for
line but everyone in the room is so
talented and funny and you know coming
up with these amazing things that it was
a while before I even you know I
understand it Mike you said that you
actually did draw on dicks own
experience leaving Twitter yeah and and
replacing people at Twitter and yeah now
I mean it was great cuz well not only
dick used to be a programmer so there's
occasionally technical questions but
also get big moves of people being fired
and hired and you know just all the ins
and outs of this world it's just great
having somebody right there I mean we
had all read the Twitter book and and
you know sometimes I find myself going
well in the book you know yeah no he's
right here you obviously you and I have
talked about how you had to deal with a
lot of scrutiny a lot of public scrutiny
at Twitter as does you know Richard and
Pied Piper Twitter has been portrayed in
a certain way by the media by certain
authors is the dysfunction is it as
dysfunctional in side as it is portrayed
in public look I think the reality of
what goes on inside these companies is
always a lot different than however
however it's portrayed in the media
whether it's being portrayed as things
are going amazingly well or it's being
portrayed as things are really
dysfunctional the reality is always
completely completely different on on
either side now Twitter is responsible
for driving major changes in the way we
watch television and the way we consume
media you know when you guys were
building the show you know what did you
think about Netflix and Amazon
and why did you ultimately decide to go
with HBO well I mean it just started out
with kind of a it was always gonna be
HBO it started out originally as them
pitching me the idea of doing a show
about gamers and game developers and HBO
pH know yeah and and I'd thought about
that and I don't know that world well
enough and that's the world where if you
get it wrong boy they those people and I
thought I'd stand a better chance
against programmers so so yeah I was
always gonna be HBO what do you think
about the whole binge viewing me would
you ever want to put all the episodes
out there at once is that yeah you mean
oh the way now looks does who knows I
mean that's kind of HBO's decision and
they're you know there's HBO now and
it's all changing so yeah I suppose it's
possible
how much creative freedom do they give
you guys unlimited they always say just
only to dip jokes this season no no no I
mean there's still you don't they don't
cap the dick jokes at all it's it's I'm
captain no they're great they're great
there's no limitations there's no
content issues now one of your writers
for the movie idiocracy tweeted recently
I never expected idiocracy to become a
documentary at a jab at Donald Trump he
surprised by how far Trump has made it
yeah I'm stressed well how about this
dick Nick Bilton who wrote the Twitter
book just wrote a piece in Vanity Fair
alleging that Silicon Valley created
Donald Trump specifically social media
and we know how often Trump uses Twitter
what do you think of that allegation
well I think he understands how to use
those platforms Donald Trump I'm
referring to you know he's quick to
tweet very early in the morning sort of
before the press cycle has gotten going
so he can be out there in front of it
and then the press cycle becomes about
whatever it was he wrote it for in the
morning or something like that and so I
think he's just got an understanding of
how to think about and leverage these
platforms in a way that he's used to his
advantage he suggests pulling the plug
on social media entirely in order to
prevent a Trump I don't know a future
Nick's crazy and he's wanted by the
authorities you know give us a without
too many spoilers give us a preview and
on the season well we sort of pick up
right where we left off Richards just
been fired and the big conflict at the
beginning of the season is what does
Richard do doesn't he fight his way back
in does he start his own competing
company so that's that's kind of where
we started and those were the questions
you know we always do a ton of research
at the beginning of every season and
those are the questions we were asking
what would actually happen what would
actually you know what would the
repercussions be does the bubble play
much of a story line or lack thereof
it's roughly Jocasta those thoughts of
whether we're in one or not yeah
I don't have any thoughts about its
references referencing it is ya be
writing this we we were talking about
just as Alec and ice were researching
that you know we'd be hearing somebody
talk about a deal like whatsapp and
flipping the value of users and all this
stuff and just kind of go on our we
didn't a giant bubble here I mean I'm
not an expert so I probably shouldn't be
talking about this on Bloomberg except
that we keep thinking okay well if the
bubble hits we'll just put will Chiron
on like nine months ago we're writing it
as if it what we mentioned like between
when we shoot it and when we air the
bubble bursts and now we're suddenly
like a period piece you're not just a in
the writers room at Silicon Valley
you're actually a venture capital that's
like a real venture capitalist now so
what do you think about whether we're in
a bubble or no what do you think about
the current climate the climate is sort
of adjusted has adjusted over the past
several months and girli wrote a great
piece about it this morning and is above
the crowd post about financings and
recaps that are coming and founders and
investors are gonna have to get used to
some down rounds on some of these
companies that have gotten way out over
their shoes and that's out of skis
rather so that's that's probably the
obviously the case and those kinds of
things are good so you're a coach to
young founders what are you telling them
about the environment you know how are
you advising them we'll just tell them
to be more thoughtful about how they're
how they're spending money you know it's
probably gonna get worse before it gets
great again or easy again and because
people are just being a lot more
thoughtful about not getting wait so far
out of our skis again so that just means
you have to be a lot more thoughtful
about how you spend and and and keeping
cost under control and thinking about
things like gross margins a lot earlier
and your a lot of your leader then you
might of two or three years ago so
you're working on something new in
addition to investing all I know is it
has to do with fitness
can you tell us building a software
platform for a group fitness like small
groups of people 5 to 10 people that are
working toward common goals and should
be should have something should have
something to show in a few few months
now the premiere is Sunday yes are you
nervous like heavily how do you feel
right now
I mean what's what's done is done at
this it's in the network's hands nothing
we can do it so I mean how long you guys
want to keep doing this show that stays
interesting yeah I I always think of
these things kind of like the way the
alcoholics do about like just one day at
a time you know like and I think you
know we write the season we rarely talk
about what we're gonna do next season
just because that's it's daunting enough
just doing one but I mean I don't know
these these kind of series seem to go
with it girls went six
I think they seemed to go six that'd be
great